[Music]
dear Aunt Lucy you sent me to London to
find a home I had a wonderful family I
think you're in great shape for a man
your age mr. Brown Wow Thank You
Paddington hang on how old do you think
I am for about 80 and I've really got to
grips with how things work I'd like to
get my Aunt Lucy a birthday present how
about these rolling shoes please Mr
Gruber be serious what's this this puppy
book is the only one of its kind and
they want a lot of money for it I'm
going to get a job and buy that book no
window cleaner
Oh
[Music]
cheerio but if you cover hold it right
there oh but I'm not the thief
[Music]
we're rich again round pay laundry due
to use only one red sock what's the
worst that can happen
afternoon chaps I want to hear all about
the investigation Paddington is innocent
he's a master of disguise well this is
breaking and entering haven't broken
anything
[Applause]
well you think you're going there
[Music]
Paddington looks for the good in all of
us and somehow he finds it if we're kind
and polite the world will be right
[Music]